hi Matt here many of us dread Small Talk
especially around the holidays yet I
think Small Talk gets a bad rap lots of
big things can happen during small talk
we can learn about others and ourselves
we can collaborate and we can set up
future opportunities today we have a
special episode for you I worked with
our friends at Harvard Business review
on a video called how to get good at
small talk and even enjoy it and it
pulls together a lot of Concepts that we
dig into on think fast talks smart the
podcast and my new book think faster
talk smarter let's listen in and enjoy
you can watch the video on Harvard
Business reviews YouTube channel and
learn much more at hbr.org without
further Ado here's how to get good at
Small Talk small talk I think is
actually a misnomer we refer to small
talk as any chitchat or just
conversation that we don't put a lot of
import on when in fact small talk is a
wonderful way of connecting bonding
learning growing what makes it so
challenging is the fact that we can't
have a script we have to just go with
what's happening in the moment we often
think that it is a test for us it's like
a tennis match where I've got to lob
something over to the person or people
I'm talking to and I hope it lands and
goes well I think a better way to look
at small talk is like that game of hacky
sack that little bean bag where
everybody's trying to keep it up all at
the same time and never have it hit the
ground if you envision your job is
collaborating with others to keep the
conversation moving rather than a hot
potato tennis match where I just need to
get it back to the other person it can
really change one how it flows and two
The Experience from your perspective all
of a sudden it's something that's
enjoyable rather than something that's
scary when you first get into a small
talk situation I think we need to
establish appropriate goals Rachel
Greenwald a Matchmaker and an academic
has this wonderful saying your goal is
to be interested not interesting a lot
of us go into these situations thinking
that we need to be really fascinating
engaging and interesting when in fact we
just need to be present and be
interested in the conversation that's
happening it also helps reduce the
anxiety many of us feel we feel like we
are being judged and the reality is you
are being judged you can red reduce the
intensity of that Spotlight we feel by
putting your attention on the other many
of us have this desire as soon as
something spontaneous happens and we
have to respond to do it as quickly as
possible we have this sense that speed
to respond in somehow is associated with
competence but really what reflects best
on your competence is an appropriate
response and appropriateness can take a
little bit of time we have all said
something we didn't mean to say say
because it wasn't clear it wasn't
appropriate pausing helps reduce that
likelihood so here are some things you
can do to help slow yourself down
paraphrasing is wonderful why not just
because you are repeating the gist of
what somebody said to make sure you're
clearly going to respond to what's asked
or what's needed but paraphrasing forces
you to slow down and listen more
carefully paraphrase isn't what a
five-year-old does who parrots back what
you've said it's a distillation of what
the other person said and when you
paraphrase it you do several things one
you validate the other person because
you're saying I heard you you're not
necessarily agreeing paraphrasing
doesn't mean agreement just means this
is what I heard and it validates the
content so you validate the person but
the content the person can say no no no
what I really meant was this so it helps
with Fidelity most of us listen just
enough to get the gist of what somebody
saying and then we immediately start
judging rehearsing and responding when I
paraphrase I have to listen super
intently I have to listen to understand
what's the bottom line of what you're
saying that slows me down and by slowing
my own thoughts down and then
paraphrasing them I buy myself some time
to really think there's always something
to say you can always ask a question my
mother-in-law was amazing at small talk
she had a black belt in small talk in
her superpower was a simple phrase she
would pause for a moment and she would
say tell me more if you are ever in in a
situation communication conversation
where you don't know what to say most of
the time you could simply say tell me
more or give me some more detail or what
did you mean about that point and just
by giving the person an opportunity to
speak again that gives you time to find
what you might want to say and to
connect to it tell me more when you say
tell me more you have to act
inquisitively if you just say tell me
more it's that but if you say tell me
yeah tell me more you know tell me more
about that yeah mistake mistakes are
normal and natural in communication we
make them all the time spontaneous
communication is about connection not
Perfection you know in film and TV
directors will ask their actors to have
multiple takes a take is just another
shot at doing the same thing so an actor
might say something in one way very
passionately or they might say it in
another way more Cur being more Curious
those are all different tapes
so I'd like people to reframe a mistake
as a missed take what you did wasn't
wrong there might be another way to do
it and we can try it again many of us
when we feel very uncomfortable in
spontaneous speaking situations we go on
to long we're discovering what we're
thinking as we're thinking it so we just
take people on the Journey of our
thought process as we're speaking and we
keep going on and on and on it's almost
a defensive technique where if I just
throw out a lot of stuff that maybe
something will stick and and people will
think oh that person's smart or they
know what they're talking about
concision is almost always better in
communication my mother has this
wonderful saying I know she didn't
create it but it's tell me the time
don't build me the clock many of us are
clock builders in these spontaneous
speaking situations and we have to
remind ourselves when we start speaking
just tell the time I I know the irony
that I'm talking about concision and I
was not concise in that answer one of
the best ways to be concise and clear is
to leverage structure structure is not a
listing of ideas it's not bullet points
structure is a logical connection of
your points it's like a recipe or a map
now this sounds ironic right we're
talking about being spontaneous and here
I am saying structure is the key to
spontaneity but we see this in our life
in many other facets if you enjoy jazz
music jazz music isn't just just random
playing jazz music follows particular
structures chord progressions
connections of notes so we can leverage
structure to help our communication be
tighter and clearer one of my favorite
structures of all time because it's so
useful in so many different situations
is is three simple questions what so
what now what the what is your idea your
product your service your belief the so
what is why is it important to the
person or people you're talking to and
the now what is what comes next maybe
I'm going to show you something take
your questions set up another
appointment when it comes to small talk
this is a magical tool imagine you're at
a corporate mixer and you're going in
and there are people in the company that
you have not yet met so if I'm engaging
you in conversation I could say hey what
brings you here that's the what when you
answer I could say oh why is that
important or why do you find that
interesting that's the so what and then
after that I can ask a question like oh
so what more are you going to do or what
are you going to do next or do you want
to join me and go over here so I've got
the now what is a question as with
anything that you're trying to learn you
have to practice it when you read
something or listen to a podcast pause
it stop your reading think what was it
about why is it important to me and how
can I use it by drilling it it becomes
more natural when we're in small talk
situations we often initiate with TR
very common phrases how are you what
brings you here what do you do these are
simple reflexive ways to get started but
they actually don't take you very far I
am a big fan of initiating through
questions but through questions that
connect to the particular context and
environment that I'm in just the other
day I was in a situation for small talk
and the very first thing I did I came up
to somebody I didn't know and I said
this is amazing to me there are more
people in this room wearing blue shirts
than I think I've seen in a long time
and the person said you know what you're
right that's really interesting and all
the a sudden the conversation was off
and running all I did was notice
something in the environment initiating
with something that pequ somebody's
curiosity something that might be
highlighting something that's not known
or commonly discussed in the moment can
really invite people in versus Hi how
are you and they say fine well now I'm
back to where I started and it's even
more Awkward right perhaps more
challenging than initiating small talk
is getting out of small talk many of us
rely on biology oh I'm thirsty I'm going
to go get a drink I'm hungry or I need
to go to the bathroom biology is not
necessarily the best exit for these
circumstances I love an approach I
learned from Rachel Greenwald it's
called The White Flag approach if you
know anything about auto racing prior to
the last lap the final lap they wave a
white flag to signal to all the drivers
that the race is ending as you're
Drawing Near to the end of the
conversation either because you need to
leave you want to leave or the
conversation has sort of run its course
you signal that you say I need to go in
a moment but and this is where you ask
one last question provide one L bit of
feedback so you you continue the
conversation on for a little bit so it
might sound something like this uh I
need to get going because there's some
friends over there I need to meet but
before I go I want to know just a little
bit more about that trip you were
telling me about to Hawaii and together
you can draw the conversation to an end
rather than you abruptly saying oh I
need to go to the bathroom or wow that
looks like good food over there it it's
just a much better cleaner way to end a
small talk
conversation I hope you now have some
ideas you can put into practice right
away about how to be better at Small
Talk thanks again to the team at Harvard
Business review for making the original
video go check out their videos on their
YouTube channel and while you're there
check out my appearance on their
Flagship podcast hbr idea cast where I
discuss impromptu speaking keeping
composure under pressure and making the
right impression that's in the hbr idea
cast podcast feed you can find all their
videos and podcasts at hbr.org